a teen seriously hurt after crashing his
motorcycle now recovering at umc
madison kimbrough has been in touch with
the 16 year old's family and friends and
she's live in the west valley with more
tonight madison
the crash happened last tuesday right
around in this area near palo verde high
school an area known for several bike
crashes over the years but luckily this
rider made it out alive
he's always been a passionate about like
bikes in general he always enjoyed it so
it was kind of like you know he was
really excited he got the harley and it
was kind of his stream right now a dream
turned into a disaster as 16-year-old
bryson bradshaw was riding his 2007
harley-davidson night rod going west on
ulta when he veered left hit the median
and was thrown into a tree bradshaw
flown by helicopter to umc trauma in
critical condition and is currently
recovering at umc after undergoing
several extensive surgeries his friends
say even with so many crashes happening
across the valley especially in this
particular area they didn't expect this
it was kind of a big shock
none of us expected this to happen to
him it was just shocking couldn't really
believe it at first it's unknown if
speeding was a factor in this crash but
for mo lopez owner of vegas power sports
letting a teen ride such a dense piece
of equipment like a night rod is not
ideal very fast very heavy before you
know it you're going 100 miles an hour
within seconds you know it's a very very
fast definitely not a beginner's
motorcycle i would say
and according to bryson's family he has
undergone nine blood transfusions with
four surgeries and more to come we have
a link to his gofundme page up on our
website reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now